Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen endlich mal wieder auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen blicken. Es wird die allerhöchste Zeit für die erste Ligatour dieser Saison, 2022-23. Und die hört ihr jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 227. Ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Wir sprechen hier über die Europäischen Top-Ligen und haben deswegen auch wieder eine ganze Reihe von tollen Gästen hier. Ich begrüße zum einen Alexis Menuge. Hallo Alexis.
Hallo zusammen.
Hattest du einen schönen Sommer?
Ja, kurz Urlaub gemacht im Juni und dann schon die Vorfreude auf diese fantastische Saison mit fast jeden Tag Spiele überall.
Man weiß nicht, ob man da eine Mü-Ironie gerade rausgehört hat.
Je mehr Spiele in der Champions League, desto besser.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Für freie Sportjournalistinnen und Journalisten ist das sehr gut. Ähnlich wird es wahrscheinlich bei Hendrik Buchheister sein. Wobei, der hat ja jetzt eine seltsame, kurze Pause bekommen. Hallo Hendrik, wie geht es dir?
Ja, mir geht es gut. Wir hatten uns ja im Sommer gehört am Ende der EM der Frauen, die ich gemacht habe. Das war cool. Und genau, jetzt läuft der Betrieb schon wieder auf vollen Touren.
Läuft wieder auf vollen Touren. Also war das jetzt kein Wochenende zum Durchlaufen, was dir da beschert wurde durch das Ableben der Queen? Okay, das hast du diplomatisch bestmöglich ausgedrückt. Das hat sich viel weniger despektierlich angehört als meine Formulierung. Chapeau dafür, Hendrik. Und ich begrüße neben mir sitzen Christian Bernhard. Schön, Christian, dass du hier bist. Wie war dein Sommer?
Hallihallo in die Runde. Ja, schön war er. Und irgendwie ist jetzt das Gefühl mit den ganzen englischen Wochen, die wir jetzt ja schon seit ein paar Dingen haben, dass die Saison irgendwie schon wieder ewig läuft. Eigentlich hat sie gerade erst angefangen, aber man ist schon wieder voll drin.
Aber absolut. Wir haben schon wieder so viele Themen, dass sie gar nicht alle in diese Sendung passen werden. Später werdet ihr auch noch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Fabian Pakulat hören zu La Liga. Denen haben wir aus terminlichen Gründen gesondert, ausgezeichnet, aufgezeichnet und natürlich auch ausgezeichnet. Das ist ja eine Auszeichnung hier zu sein. Das werdet ihr hören. Aber jetzt wollen wir beginnen und ein bisschen zwischen den Ligen herumspringen. Jeder der Gäste hat mir drei Themen mitgebracht. Und Alexi, du darfst mal mit deinem ersten Beginn. Du möchtest uns von einer Sensation erzählen. Und diese Sensation, sie rangiert nach sieben gespielten Spieltagen auf Platz drei und kommt aus Lens.
Ja, der Racing Club Lens war schon letzte Saison ein Thema, weil diese Mannschaft aus dem Norden Frankreichs 98 Meister sensationell gewesen ist. Sie war schon letzte Saison im ersten Tabellen Drittel und ist nur in einer Europapokalifikation am allerletzten oder in der allerletzten Minute gescheitert. Am letzten Spieltag gegen Monaco, da hätte man einen Sieg gebraucht und das ging 2-2 aus. Und mit einem Sieg wäre Lens fünfter geworden. Also man sieht schon, dass diese Mannschaft, die erst vor zwei Jahren aufgestiegen ist, nach drei oder vier Jahren in der zweiten Liga wieder gut angekommen ist in der Liga 1. Sie ist für mich vergleichbar mit der Union Berlin, von der Spielweise, von der Entwicklung, von den finanziellen Möglichkeiten. Ich glaube, bei allem Respekt, dass die Stimmung im Stadtfeld Felix Poulard nur ein Stück besser ist als in Berlin, auch wenn es Berlin fantastisch ist. Aber da ist noch ein Stück, da müsste noch ein Teil arbeiten. Da ist in Lens vielleicht mit Marseille die beste Stimmung Frankreichs. Die einen sagen, es wäre nicht gut für die Konkurrenzfähigkeit Frankreichs, wenn Lens in die Champions League mal einzigen sollte. Aber für die Stimmung auswärts sind sie immer dabei. Es ist eine kleine Stadt, wo der Fußball einen sehr wichtigen Platz eingenommen hat. In dieser Hinsicht wäre Lens eher mit Schalke vergleichbar. Diese Mannschaft steht völlig da oben. Sie haben nicht nur überrascht von den Ergebnissen her, sondern auch von der Spielweise mit einem attraktiven Fußball. Eine weitere Parallele zur Union oder Freiburg ist übrigens, dass man immer wieder die besten Spieler verkauft, wie im Sommer Ducouré zu Crystal Palace, wie der Ex-Bielefelder Jonathan Klos nach Olympique Marseille, oder Calimuendo, der Stürmer, der von PSG aus geliehen war und jetzt für den Rhein auf der Reaktion geht. Nichtsdestotrotz ist die Mannschaft noch besser als letztes Saison. Marseille hat sich klug verstärkt. Schon beim Trainingsauftrag wie die Union hatte man fast alle Neuzugänge eingepackt. Da arbeitet man sehr akribisch, sehr professionell mit Leuten, die mit Herz und Leidenschaft arbeiten. Das lohnt sich. Da profitieren wir natürlich von der schlechten.
Arbeit bei den größeren Vereinen wie Lyon, Monaco oder Nizza. Du hast so viele Vergleiche bemüht, u.a. mit der Union Berlin. Da hängt viel am Trainer, dass es eben so geschafft wird, die Abgänge aufzufangen. Ähnlich ist es auch beim SC Freiburg mit Christian Streich. Wie kann L'Anse das dann eben auffangen, dass man gute Spieler abgibt und dennoch den sportlichen Erfolg hat?
Definitiv, das hätte ich fast vergessen. Der Trainer ist eigentlich die wichtigste Person bei dieser steilen Entwicklung der L'Anseur. Der Spitzenname ist auch geil. Saint-Héor, also Blut und Gold. Frank Aes übernahm die Mannschaft, als die L'Anseur in der 2. Liga war. Seitdem ist er geblieben, war auch heiß und warm im Sommer, aber er hat seinen Vertrag verlängert. Er identifiziert sich voll mit seiner Aufgabe. Er hat auch sehr viel Macht, sodass er auch was zu sagen hat bei den Neuverpflichtungen oder bei Spielerverkäufen. Er hat sich wirklich toll entwickelt. Ich hoffe, dass er auch länger bleibt, wie Urs Fischer in Berlin oder Christian Streich in Freiburg, weil er wirklich für die Hauptarbeit sorgt, dass es da so einen derartigen Erfolg gibt. Ich glaube, da hat er schon mindestens 50 Prozent Anteil an dieser Erfolgsgeschichte. Wenn er es schafft, seine wichtigsten Spieler zu behalten, jetzt im Winter, nach der WM, weil einige auch heiß umworben werden, dann ist wirklich für Lance in dieser merkwürdigen Saison, wegen des komischen Spielplans, einiges drin. Ich meine nicht nur Top 5, sondern sogar Top 3. Eine wichtige Sache war auch beim Racing. Dass man den Spieler schlechthin halten konnte mit Seco Fofana, vielleicht der beste Mittelfeldspieler Frankreich momentan. Ich bin mir leid, Christian, aber ein Stück besser als Verati. Zumindest ein Podcast-Dizipin, ist aber nicht schwer.
Du kannst es nicht sehen, aber er wetzt die Messe gerade schon.
Ich sehe ihn gerade. Ich habe eine kleine Kamera installiert bei dir, Max. Auf jeden Fall war Seco Fofana umworben von Olympique Marseille, aber auch von PSG und am allerletzten Spieltag, am 31. August, gab es einen fantastischen Empfang mit einem Lichtspiel im Stadion Felix-Bolart nach dem Sieg gegen Lorient. Da kam Fofana, der bei diesem Spiel nicht eingewechselt wurde, weil er noch leicht verletzt war, mit einem Trikot drauf stand. 2025 hatte er gerade verlängert und das spricht Wende, was da abgeht in Nantes. Also diese Sensation wie nur andauernd, das ist auch eine gute Nachricht für den ferozistischen Vereinsfußball.
Lorz, aktuell auf Rang 3 mit fünf Siegen, zwei Unentschieden, also wirklich ganz hervorragend gestartet in diese Saison. Da kann man mal einen Blick drauf werfen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dann lasst uns mal in die Premier League kurz springen. Hendrik, da gab es ja nicht nur alles, was wir schon mal kurz angerissen haben, mit der Queen, sondern auch schon den ersten Trainerwechsel, der hier in Deutschland für großes Aufsehen gesorgt hat. Kannst du uns da mal mit reinholen, warum musste letztlich Thomas Tuchel beim FC Chelsea gehen?
Ich dachte, wir sprechen immer Scott Parker bei Bournemouth, aber es geht um Thomas Tuchel, genau. Thomas Tuchel musste gehen nach der Niederlage in Zagreb in der Champions League und das ist gar nicht mal so überraschend, wie es vielleicht auf den ersten Blick erschien, weil über den Sommer mit den neuen Eigentümern schon so die ein oder andere Murren zu hören war. Also von Tuchel selbst über den Zustand des Kaders, über die Transfers, die nicht schnell genug gegen die Vorbereitung lief, auch sportlich insgesamt nicht gut. Es gab diese Kontroverse um Cristiano Ronaldo, die der neue Besitzer Todd Böhli offenbar gerne verpflichtet hätte nach einem Treffen mit Ronaldos Berater. Tuchel hat sich im Endeffekt auch durchgesetzt, aber das hat ganz offenbar auch dazu beigetragen, dass sich das Verhältnis zwischen Besitzer und Trainer verschlechtert hat. Was dann dazu kam, ist, dass die Saison sportlich nicht so lief, wie man sich das erwartet hat. Das ist aber gar nicht mal der Hauptgrund, dass es so ist, dass die Besitzer um Todd Böhli schon vor dieser Niederlage gegen Sargab entschieden hatten, Tuchel abzulösen. Man hat sich dann, so hieß es dann in der offiziellen Mitteilung, hat man als Begründung angeführt, man ist jetzt 100 Tage, sind die neuen Besitzer im Amt und es ist ein guter Zeitpunkt, um diesen Wechsel vorzunehmen. Das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen konstruiert. Andererseits von amerikanischen Eigentümern kennt man es ja auch, dass sie sehr auf Zahlen und Daten und Analyse fixiert sind. Von daher kann das schon stimmen und im Endeffekt, dass sportlich ist, wie gesagt, nicht der Hauptgrund gewesen, sondern dass es ganz offenbar bei den Besitzern die Erkenntnis gab, dass Thomas Tuchel nicht der Trainer ist, mit dem man langfristig dieses Projekt bei Chelsea voranbringen will. Man hat es bei Tuchel so ein bisschen gemerkt in den letzten Wochen. Er wirkte sehr leicht reizbar, sehr emotional. Die Szenen von diesem Spiel gegen Totten haben wahrscheinlich noch einige vor Augen, wo er dann Antonio Conte…
Den nennen wir als Handschlag mit Antonio Conte.
Genau, wo die sich halt weiter geprügelt hätten nach dem Spiel.
Christian wird schon wieder die Messer. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das heißt.
Und das ist jetzt, was man von Thomas Tuchel ja nicht unbedingt so kennt. Dazu kam auch noch, dass es in dem Verein ja einige Umbauten gab seit dem Wechsel der Besitzer. Marina Granovskaia, die Sportdirektorin, de facto Sportdirektorin ist gegangen. Bruce Buck, der Präsident, ist gegangen. Der internationale Chefstrauer ist ebenfalls gegangen. Peter Tschech ist gegangen, sportlicher Berater, zu dem Tuchel einen guten Draht hatte, genauso zu Granovskaia. Da hat er sich auch mehrmals geäußert, dass das jetzt alles nicht unbedingt so nach seiner Vorstellung ist, wie der Club umgebaut wird. Von daher ist es in letzter Konsequenz erwartbar gewesen, dass die Besitzer dieser Entscheidung treffen. Was so nicht zu erwarten war, ist der Zeitpunkt. Man hat eine Transferphase, die gerade zu Ende gegangen ist, wo Chelsea mehr Geld ausgegeben hat als jemals einen Verein zuvor in einer Transferperiode, nämlich umgerechnet mehr als 300 Millionen Euro. Einige Transfers waren ganz offensichtliche Tucheltransfers. Das beste Beispiel ist natürlich Aubameyang, der immer aus Barcelona gerodet hat. Von daher ist es ein bisschen wild, dass man diese Transferphase mit dem Trainer bestreitet, ihm großen Einfluss auf diese Transfers ausüben lässt und dann eine Woche danach ihn entlässt.
Ja, es scheint einen Kulturwandel zu geben, tatsächlich mit den neuen Besitzern. Da gab es eine ganze Reihe von Artikeln, für in denen das erklärt wurde. Du hast ja auch gerade nochmal die anderen Namen genannt, die auch nicht mehr bei Chelsea sind, die da waren. Und unter anderem soll wohl Thomas Tuchel auch viel mehr in Meetings gebeten worden sein von den Besitzern, wo er dann gar nicht immer selbst hingegangen ist, manchmal auch seine Assistenten geschickt hat, weil er gesagt hat, ich möchte auch mal coachen. Und es gibt zumindest das Gerücht, dass da auch mal eine 4-4-3-Formation auf der Tafel angemalt worden wäre. Also es gibt auch noch eine gewisse Distanz zum Fußball, sage ich mal, der neuen Besitzer.
Ja, das ist so. Also diese Böli-Gruppe, die sind fachfremd. Das sind keine Fußball-Experten. Die sind in den USA beteiligt an den LA Dodgers, aus der Magic Baseball, an den LA Lakers aus dem Basketball. Unter anderem im Fußball sind die neu und müssen sich erst einmal einfinden. Dieses Beispiel von der 4-4-3-Formation, was im Athletic, glaube ich, stand und vom Verein dementiert wurde, aber es ist auch in der Welt, illustriert es natürlich sehr, sehr gut, dass diese Besitzer sich im Fußball erst noch einfinden müssen. Du sprichst es an, es soll einen Kulturwandel geben, also dass der Trainer stärker eingebunden ist in Diskussionen, wenn es zum Beispiel um Spielertransfers geht, wenn es um Spielweisen geht. Tuchel musste sich offenbar auch seine Taktik wohl erklären, den neuen Besitzern, und da gab es auch einen Austausch. Also, sehen, dass die Besitzer Tuchel hat das wohl eher als Eingriff in seine Arbeit empfunden. Und man weiß ja auch von Thomas Tuchel, dass er jemand ist, der sich am liebsten auf die Arbeit, auf den Platz, auf den Trainingsplatz konzentriert und alles andere, was im Verein so vor sich geht, dann auch anderen Leuten überlässt. Also, es gibt ja dieses berühmte Beispiel aus der Tuchel-Biografie von Daniel Meuren und Tobias Schächter. Sehr, sehr gutes Buch, sehr lesenswert, wo Christian Heidel erzählt, dass man Tuchel wohl mal gebeten hätte oder ihn mal angebracht hätte, vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr wie Jürgen Klopp auch mit den Fans zu interagieren und so weiter, und da ist Tuchel halt offenbar durch die Ecke gegangen, weil erstens diese Klopfergleiche mag er natürlich nicht und zweitens er hat aber auch gesagt, meine Arbeit ist auf dem Trainingsplatz und das scheint halt auch ein Problem gewesen zu sein mit den neuen Besitzern bei Chelsea. Es ist interessant, dass du sagst, es soll einen Kulturwandel geben und den soll es auch geben, aber dass der erste Schritt auf den Weg zu diesem Kulturwandel eigentlich so typische Chelsea-Abramowitsch-Kultur ist. Nach relativ kurzer Zeit einen unbestritten, erfolgreichen Trainer zu feuern und direkt den neuen zu holen, das ist natürlich ein bisschen ein Widerspruch. Allerdings, der neue Mann, den Chelsea verpflichtet hat, Graham Potter, zu Last but not of Albion gewesen, ist dann natürlich schon jemand, der diesen Kulturwandel, diesen angestrebten, postulierten Kulturwandel sehr gut personifiziert, weil Potter jemand ist, der für seine langfristige Arbeit bekannt ist, der dafür bekannt ist, etwas aufzubauen, der dafür bekannt ist, einen starken Fokus auf die menschliche Entwicklung der Spieler zu legen. Es gibt dieses berühmte Beispiel aus einer Zeit bei Östersund, dass er seine Spieler Schwannsee aufführen lassen hat. Das wird der Betrace natürlich nicht tun, aber es ist ein ganz anderer Trainertyp und auch ein ganz anderer Mensch als Tuchel und Tuchel.
Man muss dazusagen, er hat Schwannsee aufhören lassen. Also jetzt nicht mannschaftsintern, sondern vor Publikum, weil das Teil eines kulturellen Abends für die Stadt Östersund war, für die Region Östersund.
Genau. Was Grant Potter macht, ist, dass er versucht, seine Spieler so gut es geht, auch mal aus ihrer Komfortzone zu holen, was zur menschlichen Weiterentwicklung der Spieler beiträgt. Aber auch dazu, dass man auf den Platz möglicherweise auch mal Risiken geht und Selbstvertrauen hat. Das hat er gemacht in Östersund. Das wird er bei Chelsea nicht machen. Schade. Er weiß natürlich auch, dass gewisse Methoden bei einem Verein auf einem gewissen Level funktionieren, aber nicht bei Chelsea. Er ist insofern ein Novum bei Chelsea, weil Chelsea ja normalerweise große Namen mit vielen Titeln verpflichtet. Ancelotti war Trainer, natürlich José Mourinho, Güss Hedding mehrmals, Frank Lampard, kann man sagen, hatte noch keine Titel, aber war natürlich auch ein großer Name bei Vereinsikone. Da ist Graeme Potter natürlich ein anderer Trainer, der zum ersten Mal in dieser Größenordnung trainiert. Wie das mittelfristig funktioniert, wird sehr interessant zu sehen sein.
Wir werden uns das genau anschauen. Mit Graeme Potter bei Chelsea auf jeden Fall viel, viel schon wieder los in der Premier League. Und ein bisschen was ist natürlich auch los in der Serie A. Christian, da grüßt uns Napoli von Tabellenplatz 1 auf Wemmler mit Tabellen nach sechs Spieltagen natürlich noch vorsichtig sein muss. Wir haben gerade drei Teams, die 14 Punkte haben. Napoli, Atalanta und Milan. Das sind dann auch gemeinsam mit Juventus, die insgesamt dann vier Teams, die noch ungeschlagen sind. Und gerade über Spallettis Napoli willst du gerne mit uns sprechen oder uns davon erzählen. Was gibt es denn da so zu berichten?
Ja, sehr gerne. Fangen wir mit Napoli an. Die haben es sich mehr als verdient. Ein kurzer Rückblick in den Sommer. Da war ja einiges an Skepsis da. Lorenzo Insigne weg, der Kapitän-Identifikationsfigur, Colibaly weg, Dries Mertens weg, Ospina im Tor weg. Also nicht nur sehr wichtige Spieler, sondern auch ganz klar das Führungsgremium der Mannschaft. Und dementsprechend, ich war auch ziemlich skeptisch, ob sie das einfach aufgefangen kriegen. Und jetzt sind wir zwar erst nach sechs Spieltagen. Ist klar, brauchen wir alles nicht so hochhängen. Aber es scheint so aus, als hätten sie es aufgefangen bekommen. Klar, das 4-1 gegen Liverpool sticht da extrem raus. Da hat man gesehen, welche Spielfreude, welche guten Abläufe Napoli immer noch hat. Und da sind wir dann eben bei Spalletti. Denn der Trainer ist ja gleichgeblieben. Und ich finde, dass diese Saisonstartphase wieder ganz eindeutig zeigt, dass Spalletti ein sehr, sehr, sehr guter Fußballlehrer ist. Denn wenn man sich Napoli anschaut, sowohl letztes als auch jetzt, du erkennst eine ganz klare Idee, sehr gute Abläufe, wirklich spielerisch mit Ball. Da ist viel Spielfreude da. Wenn du dir dieses Mittelfeld Lobotka Anguissan anschaust, die haben Liverpool auch ein paar wie die, die da auch im Zentrum dominiert haben. Also das spricht schon sehr vieles für Spalletti einfach, weil Spalletti auch immer wieder mal kritisch beäugt wird. Und gerade wenn es dann vielleicht darum geht, dass es vielleicht den Schritt, den er noch machen muss, wenn seine Mannschaft in Titelnähe ist, dass man dann vielleicht auch diese mentale Härte hat, das auch durchzuziehen. Napoli war ja vergangenen Saison auch ziemlich lang oben mit dran und hat dann eigentlich in einer Phase abreißen lassen, wo es nicht zu erwarten war, wo dann die Meilener davongezogen sind. Also das muss er vielleicht noch zeigen. Aber was eben wirklich den spielerischen Ansatz seiner Mannschaft, die Lösungsmöglichkeiten, die die Mannschaft hat, betrifft, ist er wirklich große Klasse und das zeigt sich in diesen ersten Spieltagen. Napoli ist gleich mal mit fünf Toren am ersten Spieltag, vier am zweiten gestartet. Also haben sie diese ganze Spielfreude gezeigt. Es war ein ganz wichtiges Spiel, weil nach diesem euphorischen Liverpool-Abend war ja klar, wurden alle gefeiert und das Ballett gleich gesagt, so, das müssen wir jetzt aber halt regelmäßig abrufen. Und dann hast du gleich ein Heimspiel gegen Spezia, was so ein kleiner Stolperstein sein könnte. Und ja, was machen sie? Sie tun sich lange schwer, aber sie gewinnen es in der 89. Weil Raspardori das Tor noch macht. Und das, glaube ich, zeigt so einen kleinen Reifeprozess, den die Mannschaft auch weiterhin nimmt. Und wie gesagt, die fußballerischen Tatsachen, Qualitäten sind da. Und ja, müssen wir jetzt logisch noch auf ein, zwei Personal, den Eingehenden. Einer eben, wie gesagt, den hatten wahrscheinlich die wenigsten auf dem Zettel. Lorenzo Insigne war weg, diese Position links außen war frei. Und dann kommt ein gewisser Quara Quaratzkelia nach Neapel. Und ja, wir können jetzt sagen, ein paar Wochen später ist Quaramenia in Neapel ausgebrochen. Ja, es gibt auch schon so Wortspielchen, überraschenderweise, wie Quaradonna. Ich glaube, die würde ich jetzt mal vielleicht ein bisschen hinten anstellen.
Wortspiel im Fußball ist sowieso das Schlimmste.
Ja, aber Fakt ist, der junge Georger, eingeschlagen wie eine Eins. Also wirklich mutig, brutales Eins gegen Eins, Abschlussstärke. Ich glaube, nach zwei Spieltagen auch schon drei Tore. Eins mit links, eins mit rechts, eins bei Kopf. Ja, Liverpool erinnert sich auch noch ganz gut an ihn in diesem ersten Spiel. Also der ist sozusagen das neue Gesicht, das Gesicht, das sicherlich die wenigsten auf dem Zettel hatten. Aber das zeigt, dass Napoleon auch was Scouting und so betrifft, als Sportdirektor Giuntoli, der sicher nicht oft genannt wird, aber der da im Hintergrund eine sehr, sehr gute Arbeit macht. Und ja, dementsprechend ist Quarantjkile da das neue Gesicht. Lobotka haben wir angesprochen, Anguissa. Zentral in der Abwehr auch ganz wichtig. Koulibaly ist ja weg und Koulibaly war mehr als ein wichtiger Innenverteidiger. Il Comandante, wie es Ballettin genannt hat, war wirklich die tragende Figur der Mannschaft. Da haben sie Kim aus der Türkei geholt. Der ist physisch ähnlich und hat sich auch schon wunderbar eingefügt. Das müssen wir auch noch über eine lange Zeit beobachten. Er und Rahmani haben sich sehr gut gefunden. Bei Rahmani war die Frage, ob der das jetzt schafft, nachdem Koulibaly, der ihn ja so mitgezogen hat, wenn er jetzt so ein bisschen die Führungsrolle übernimmt. Ja, hat er bisher geschafft. Kim auch schon zweimal getroffen, stark bei Offensivstandards. Die Lorenzo, neuer Kapitän, macht das richtig, richtig gut. Da war eben die Frage, wie wird dieses Führungsvakuum aufgefangen, macht das richtig klasse.
Spielt Diego Demme eine Rolle? Also jetzt gerade ist er verletzt, aber der ist ja so ein bisschen aus dem Fokus geraten logischerweise mit seinem Wechsel?
Ja, im Moment eben nicht, wie du es ansprichst. Er ist verletzt, ist auch schwierig sicher für ihn, jetzt wieder reinzukommen, denn Lobotka und Anguizá sind fest gesetzt. Zieliński hat einen überragenden Saisonstart gehabt. Jetzt haben sie ihn in Dombere noch geholt, auch im Sommer, noch spät. Also da ist es jetzt schon eng im Zentrum. Da ist viel Qualität. Und apropos viel Qualität, Ossimen vorne fällt jetzt verletzt aus. Fehlt sicherlich ein paar Wochen, das tut ihnen weh. Aber anders als vergangenen Saison, da war dann die 1B-Lösung, wenn nicht Mertens ganz vorne drin gespielt hat, war Petania. Jetzt nicht gegen Petania, aber bringt jetzt nicht die große Klasse mit. Jetzt hat Napoli noch Raspadouri geholt und Simone geholt von Hellas. Simone, gleich getroffener Champions League. Schaut euch vielleicht nochmal die Bilder an, wirklich überragend. Der sinkt ja zu Boden, weint gleich. Das war sein erstes Champions-League-Spiel. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, er ist der erste Argentinier seit dieses Stadion. Diego Armando Maradona heißt, der das Napoli-Trikot trägt. Und sein Vater hat noch mit Maradona zusammengespielt. Da waren wahnsinnig viele Emotionen.
Und hat er nicht auch schon ewig das Champions-League-Tattoo, das er dann geküsst hat nach seinem ersten Tor?
Genau, richtig. Noch ein emotionaler Moment an diesem emotionalen Abend. Und wie gesagt, jetzt hast du halt eine andere Qualität da hinten dran. Also Ocimen fehlt jetzt, aber jetzt kommst du halt mit Raspadouri daher, der auch jetzt gleich das entscheidende Tor macht. Und du hast Simone auch noch. Also sie sind breiter aufgestellt und sie haben einfach mit Spalletti wirklich einen Trainer, der ihnen eine extrem gute Spielweise mit auf den Weg gegeben hat und sicherlich auch weitergeben wird.
Ach, Napoli, es ist einfach, es bleibt a gift that keeps on giving. Man muss das wirklich einfach so sagen. Und im Grunde das schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten, wenn man bis in die 80er zurückgehen möchte. Ein gift that keeps on giving, das haben wir auch in der Liga und das ist PSG, Alexi. Über die willst du auch mal widersprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum PSG jetzt so wichtig ist, wenn man auf den französischen Fußball guckt. Du hast mir geschrieben, das neue PSG mit den alten Problemen. Das klingt ja schon wieder ganz fantastisch. Was ist schon wieder los bei Paris?
Ja, egal ob man den, ich glaube Paris hat jetzt 12, 13 Spieler verkauft, die gar nicht mehr erwünscht waren vom neuen Trainerstab um den Franzosen Christophe Galtier. Zur Erinnerung, das war schon eine riesen Überraschung, dass er PSG übernahm, weil er ist ja ein No-Name in Europa, muss man ganz klar sagen. Es wäre genau, wenn Thomas Reis Bayern-Trainer geworden wäre. Und jetzt hat man Galtier bei PSG.
Hat er jetzt wieder Zeit?
Ja, vielleicht, wenn Paris morgen 10-0 in Haifa verliert. Sonst muss er sich ein bisschen gedulden. Also, nach dem katastrophalen Aus bei Madrid am 10. März wussten wir, dass es vielleicht fast eine Revolution gegen Paris Saint-Germain gibt, weil man aus diesen bisherigen Niederlagen im Europapokal die Lehre entziehen möchte, um besser abzuschneiden. Und dass die Verantwortlichen stets auf große Namen setzen, aber kein Kollektiv. Weil unter Pochettino haben wir gar kein gutes Spiel gesehen. Es war keine Handschrift zu erkennen. Es gab keine Taktik. Er hatte schnell aufgegeben, weil er wusste, die Spieler haben die Macht. Neymar, Mbappé und Messi haben die Macht. Und er hat ähnlich zu sagen. Die Spieler kamen zu spät zum Training. Oder ging es ihm fast jeden Tag. Und vielleicht in einem betrugenen Zustand wie bei Neymar. Das ist auch bewiesen worden. Kennst du die Geschichte nicht? Ich konzentriere mich immer so auf Sport. Ja, das ist ja bekannt. Du brauchst nur in seinen Augen schauen. Auch wenn er die ganze Nacht Pokern spielt, alles andere ist professionell. Das haben die Entscheider aus Doha mitbekommen. Da wollten sie einfach eine gewisse Revolution einführen. Damit Paris Saint-Germain näher an seinem Hauptziel kommt, nämlich dem Champions-League-Triumph, aber auch damit sein Image besser wird. Wie du weißt, hoffe ich zumindest, nach dem Aus in Madrid, im März, danach gab es einen Streik der Fans gegenüber den Spielern und dem Verein, weil man nicht einverstanden war, dass sich diese großen Stars nicht mit dem Verein identifizieren, dass sie nichts wissen über den Verein, über seine Geschichte, seine Vergangenheit, dass sie bei Ballverlust stehen bleiben gegen Real Madrid, dass sie beim 1-1 in Madrid, beim Benzemausgleich komplett verloren haben, dass sie auseinandergefallen sind, obwohl sie noch verlifiziert waren. Das war eine alte Pechik-Krankheit. Und deswegen hat man dann gesagt, wir haben eh einen zu übigen Kader, zumindest quantitativ, ich nenne nur Draxler, Kehrer aus deutscher Sicht, die einfach beim neuen Trainerstab keine Rolle spielen. Das war schon die herkules Aufgabe vom neuen Sportdirektor Luis Campos, diese Spieler loszueisen bzw. zu verkaufen. Und dafür dann vier, fünf, sechs Spieler, die nicht den klangvolleren Namen haben, aber die fleißig sind, die viel arbeiten, die sich für die Mannschaft zerreißen. Und deswegen hat man Spieler geholt wie Fabian Luis, wie Soler, Renato Sanches am Ende des Transfermarktes und auch Eki Tike, der neue französische Hoffnungsträger im Sturm. Damit man ein bisschen bescheidener auftritt. Damit auch der Kader besser gestaltet ist, um ein besseres Image zu haben. Und Galte, der sehr bekannt dafür ist, dass er Bodenstöning ist, ein Fußballbesessen, ein Detailbesessen. Aber der hat noch nie so eine Mannschaft trainiert, mit so vielen Stars. Er hat heute oder morgen Abend in der Champions League sein achtes Champions-League-Spiel. Bis jetzt hat er fünf davon verloren. Und das war mit Lille klar. Aber er muss sich erst einmal den Respekt verschaffen. Bis jetzt läuft es ganz gut. Aber wie man gesehen hat, beim Elfmeter gegen Montpellier in der Liga gab es wieder einen Streit zwischen Neymar, der Schütze Nummer eins, also Ego ist ohne Ende. Heute Morgen haben wir erfahren, dass MBAP doch nicht für drei Jahre verlängert hat, sondern für zwei Jahre plus eins. Das heißt, dass er im kommenden Sommer wieder heiß umworben wird. Das fängt wieder an und dann werden die Pégés mit ihm zu verlängern. Aber wahrscheinlich erst Ende August, nachdem die Liga schon losgestartet ist. Es ist und bleibt ein Zirkusverein, auch wenn der neue Trainerstab versucht, es besser hinzukriegen. Das ist auch gut, glaube ich. Der Sportdirektor ist auch für Paris Saint-Germain ein Segen, weil er auch für viel Unruhe im Verein gesorgt hat. Er hat für die Thomas-Tuchel-Entlassung gesorgt. Er hat für die ganze Unruhe gesorgt, auch in der Mannschaft bei PSG. Er hat es auch nie geschafft, irgendeinen Spieler zu verkaufen, während jetzt seine Nachfolger zwölf auf einmal auf –das muss man auch noch ganz kurz präzisieren zum Schluss –dass von diesen zwölf Spielern, glaube ich, sind elf ausgeliehen. Ein Jahr ohne Option. Und zum Beispiel bei Julian Draxler, der kommt im kommenden Sommer zurück nach Paris. Und 80 Prozent seines Gehalts übernimmt PSG.
Na gut, Geld ist ja nicht das Problem bei PSG. Aber ich sehe, was du meinst mit den alten Problemen und habe irgendwie so das Gefühl, über PSG werden wir noch das ein oder andere Mal hier sprechen im Rasenfunk. Da werden wir gar nicht drumherum kommen. Jetzt wollen wir aber auch über ein Team in der Premier League noch mal kurz sprechen, das auch hin und wieder hier schon mal zur Sprache kam. Liverpool, Hendrik, steckt ein bisschen in der Krise. Zumindest war das die Überschrift, die du diesem Segment gegeben hast. In Zahlen bedeutet das, dass man aktuell nur 9 Punkte hat nach 6 Spielen, 2 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und eine Niederlage. Was ist los bei Liverpool? So ein bisschen am Rande hat man es ja, glaube ich, auch hier in Deutschland mitbekommen. Es gab einmal einen riesigen, hohen Sieg, aber sehr, sehr viel Stückwerk dazwischen.
Ja, absolut. Es gab das 9-0 gegen Bournemouth, der erste Saisonsieg, der aber nicht darüber hinaus tauschen konnte, dass der Saisonstart für Liverpool insgesamt ziemlich stottrig war. Also mit zwei Unentschieden, mit einer Niederlage dann auch bei Manchester United, die davor, wie erinnert uns auch, gerade 4-0 in Brentford verloren hatten. Und das letzte Mal Liga 0-0 gegen Everton. Das kann man alles noch so ein bisschen abtun als schwieriger Start, so ein bisschen Hangover noch von der letzten Saison, wo man ja jedes Pflichtspiel, was möglich war, auch bestritten hat. Im Endeffekt zwei Spiele vom Quadruppel entfernt war und das dann halt aber nicht gewonnen hat. Also da gab es relativ viele Faktoren, die Liverpool so ein bisschen entlastet haben, plus natürlich die Verletzungssituation. Also gerade im Mittelfeld hat Liverpool viele Verletzte zu beklagen. Und das hat sich aber durch diese Niederlage in Neapel 1 zu 4 die Sichtweise wirklich geändert und dass man jetzt halt nicht mehr von einem irgendwie schleppenden Staat sprechen kann. Es ist halt eine ausgewachsene Krise. Jürgen Klopp selbst hat auch Alarm geschlagen. Er hat jetzt gerade nochmal gesagt, dass es eine Horrorshow war in Neapel, dass es das schlechteste Spiel seiner Amtszeit war. Da kann man natürlich darüber streiten, ob das so ist. Es gab ja auch unter anderem einen 2 zu 7 gegen Aston Villa in der Corona-Saison. Aber fest steht halt, dass Liverpool in einer Krise ist. Jürgen Klopp hat auch gesagt, dass der Verein sich jetzt ein bisschen selbst neu erfinden muss. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das passieren soll. Die Transferphase ist bekanntlich geschlossen. Man kann jetzt nicht noch groß einkaufen. Der Kader ist der, der er ist. Man kann auch nicht mit Spielern wie Salah oder Van Dijk, also großen Namen, austauschen. Von daher, was Klopp wahrscheinlich gemeint hat, ist weniger eine Neuerfindung im personellen Sinne oder möglicherweise auch im taktisch-spielerischen Sinne. Jürgen Klopp hat auch schon gesagt, diese hohe Verteidigung, für die er immer dann kritisiert wird, wenn es nicht läuft gegen Napoli, da wird er auch nichts dran ändern, weil das im Endeffekt die Basis für sein Spiel ist, für das Gegenpressing, für die schnelle Rückeroberung des Balls. Da wird auch nichts dran geändert. Das heißt, was er mit dieser Neuerfindung meint, ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen so ein Reset, was die alten Werte betrifft und das, was Liverpool hat, auszeichnet, also eine hohe Intensität, dass man den Gegner in der ganzen Mannschaft früh anläuft, dass man die Engduelle für sich gewinnt, weil das nämlich alles so Sachen waren, die halt im Moment nicht zu sehen sind. Also Liverpool wirkte zuletzt erstaunlich matt und es hat diese Energie gefehlt, die man von Liverpool kennt. Dazu kommt, dass wichtige Spieler, Schlüsselspieler in der Formkrise sind, also Salah, wie ich schon gesagt habe, seit seiner Vertragsverlängerung, ist er nicht der, den man kennt, wie man ihn kennt. Das hat sich jetzt noch zum Start dieser Saison fortgesetzt. Vigil van Dijk, der immer so ein bisschen die Aura des Unantastbaren und Makellosen hat. Es gibt diese Statistik, dass er in 150 Spielen keinen einzigen Elfmeter verursacht hat. Jetzt hat er in sieben Spielen schon zwei verursacht, gegen Pullen zum Start, gegen Neapel zuletzt. Schwent Alexander-Arnold ist auch jemand, den man erwähnen muss in diesem Zusammenhang. Er ist wahnsinnig wichtig für das Spiel nach vorne. Er ist im Grunde so ein Spielmacher auf der rechten Außenverteidigerposition. Aber er ist halt –das muss man auch sagen –im Verteidigen nicht der Stärkste. Er hat offensichtliche Schwächen in der Rückwärtsbewegung und im Stellungsspiel. Das ging Neapel auch mehrmals ausgenutzt wurde. Und so setzt sich so ein Mosaik zusammen aus ganz vielen kleinen Problemfeldern, die sich dann halt zu dieser Krise zusammenfügen, die man jetzt hat. Ich glaube, und so ein bisschen schwebt über dem Ganzen natürlich. Aber das ist eher ein Medienthema. Die berühmte siebte Saison von Klopp. Also das Jahr, wo er sich aus Mainz verabschiedet hat, wo er dann mit Dortmund plötzlich tabellenletzter war und dann gesagt hat, ein großer Kopf muss weg, und das ist meiner. Und das siebte Jahr ist jetzt halt auch in Liverpool. Er wurde sogar neulich nach diesem Neapelspieler schon gefragt. Das war am Tag, nachdem Tuchel entlassen wurde, ob er sich denn jetzt auch Sorgen macht um seinen Job. Und wie fand er die Frage? Und da ist dann diese Schlussfolgerung, aber er auch ein deutscher Trainer, der auch gerade Probleme hat, ist dann halt aber die falsche Schlussfolgerung, weil FSC, also die Besitzer von Liverpool, ihm natürlich vertrauen und die würden ihn nicht entlassen. Im Zweifelsfall müsste dieser Entscheidung glaube ich Klopp schon selber treffen und auch davon ist er natürlich weit entfernt. Es gab ja die Situation auch schon mal in der vorvergangenen Saison, die Titelverteidiger-Saison, wo es dann zwischenzeitlich diese berühmten, ich glaube sechs Warnsheim-Niederlagen nacheinander gab gegen Brighton und Burnley und Fulham, wo er auch ausgebrannt gewirkt hat. Und das ist halt jetzt nicht der Fall. Von daher glaube ich schon, dass wenn jetzt die Verletzten-Spieler zurückkommen, er natürlich alle Chancen hat. Und dass auch das, was Liverpool ausgezeichnet hat, also diese Intensität, das auch wieder in die Mannschaft injiziert. Aber es ist eine extrem interessante Phase bei Liverpool. Vielleicht gar nicht so überraschend, wenn man halt sieht, wie kräftig sie in der letzten Saison war. Jetzt spielen sie heute gegen Ajax in der Champions League. Und das ist plötzlich ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Spiel.
Wir werden beobachten, ob man da auch so passive Phasen sieht wie gegen Napoli. Das fand ich eigentlich mit am beeindruckendsten. Neben dem also konterkariert mit der Spielstärke Neapels, dann aber auch eben die Passivität im Abwehrverbund. Ich weiß gar nicht, bei welchem Tor das war. Ich glaube, das war das 2 zu 0, was da gefallen ist. Da standen einfach drei Menschen, haben einfach gewartet, bis dann der tiefe Pass hinter die Kette endlich kam und dann dieses Tor erzielt werden konnte. Das war schon sehr, sehr viel. Wir gucken uns an, wie das weitergeht bei Liverpool. Wir werden jetzt schnell League A und Premier League noch abschließen, denn ihr beide habt noch Anschlusstermine. Christian, du musst dich ein bisschen gedulden, aber immerhin sitzt du bequem. Deswegen lass noch mal kurz zu Alexis zurückgehen. Alexis, du hast noch ein letztes Thema mitgebracht. Ich denke, das wird auch die Menschen sehr interessieren. Der große Zirkus in Nizza. Und ich vermute, damit meinst du nichts Sportliches.
Doch, eigentlich schon. Aber ich meine ja nicht zumindest eine Cannaballe, weil eine Cannaballe gibt es nicht nur in Köln und in Düsseldorf auch in Nizza. Vielleicht auf einer anderen Art und Weise und mit weniger Alkohol als in Deutschland. Nizza hat einen reichen Eigentümer mit Ineos, Engländer, die wollten Chelsea kaufen für ein paar Milliarden Euro. Haben jetzt in Nizza, glaube ich, keine 100 Millionen ausgegeben, um den Verein wieder zu kaufen. Dann gab es auch Gerüchte vor wenigen Wochen, dass die Manchester United kaufen wollten. Also das sorgt alles für Unruhe. Man weiß nicht wirklich, was diese Engländer wollen. Dann hat man Lucien Favre installiert. Das haben aber nicht die Engländer gemacht, sondern der Präsident Jean-Pierre Rivère, der den Lulü sehr gut kennt aus seiner ersten Zeit, also zwischen Gladbach und Dortmund, wo Favre eigentlich gute Arbeit geleistet hatte in der Cote d'Azur. Erste Saison gleich Platz 3 erreicht. Nur Neapel, glaube ich, gescheitert in der Champions-League-Qualifikation. Und danach, ja, die zweite Saison, wie schon überall, wo er vorher war, bei Hertha, bei Dortmund, lief es schlechter. Und dann ging er nach zwei Jahren, weil er sein Traumangebot endlich erhielt und nach Dortmund zog. Jetzt kam er zurück nach dem Erdi Gladbarer. Überraschenderweise, weil er eigentlich klar war, mit der Borussia auch abgesagt hat, kam nach Nizza. Und er kam von den Engländern zu hören, dass er viele Spieler und seine Spieler bekommen würde. Und die Zeit verging bis dem 15., 26. Und es kam kaum Spieler. Neu dazu. Und auf einmal kamen Aaron Ramsey, Caspar Schmeichel, Ross Barkley, also alles Auslaufmodelle außer Premier League, die eh keine Chance dort mehr haben und die auf einmal nach Nizza kommen und ein schwaches Spiel nach dem anderen abliefern. Ganz sicher keine Spieler, die sich Lucien Favre gewünscht hat. Er hat trotzdem noch ein paar Spieler bekommen, wie Nicolas Pépé, wie Sofiane Diop, also technisch sehr stark, und Gaetano Laborde, der bei Rennes letzte Saison zweistellig getroffen hatte. Also man merkt schon, dass es zwar zweistellig gearbeitet wird bei Nizza. Also zwei Gleise, pardon, Favre und sein Präsident auf der einen Seite und die Engländer auf der anderen Seite, um Nizza bekannter zu machen. Nur sportlich lief es überhaupt nicht. Ohne den Sieg bei schlusslich Ajax-Job am Wochenende, stünde jetzt Nizza vorletzter. Man hat mit Hauch und Krach nur 1 zu 0 gewonnen. In der Europa League natürlich dieses 1 zu 1 gegen Köln letzte Woche, in der Europa Confluence League. Man weiß nicht, in welche Richtung es geht bei Nizza. Man hat schon mit großen Hoffnungen gestartet, als die Engländer kamen in Neos, weil die haben sehr viel Erfolg gehabt beim Segeln oder in der Formel 1. Man hatte gehofft, vielleicht gibt es endlich mal Konkurrenz für Paris Saint-Germain, aber momentan steht Nizza ganz weit weg von den ursprünglichen Ansprüchen. Dementsprechend ist man sehr besorgt, wie es bei Nizza weitergeht. Wie man Lucien Faber kennt, würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn er jetzt in der Länderspielpause das Handtuch wirft.
Alexi, haut hier wieder einen raus. Ich muss aber zugeben, ich habe ehrlicherweise dieses Thema komplett missverstanden. Ich dachte, es geht um die Ausschreitungen vor dem Kölnspiel und deren Nacharbeitung.
Nizza kam ausnahmsweise dafür. Deswegen hätte ich was sonst gesagt. Aber klar, das war auch ein trauriges Kapitel. Wir haben es gerne erspart. Bei Marseille-Frankfurt wird es auch eng, glaube ich, in der Champions League. In der Provence traurige Geschichten und traurige Bilder. Ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass die Hooligans immer mehr wieder von sich aufmerksam machen und dass immer wieder negative Schleigzeilen sorgen. Das ist schon schade, weil wir dachten, das Problem ist gelöst. Aber was da in Nizza passiert ist mit den Köln-Fans, die sich abgesprochen hatten –also nicht Fans, Entschuldigung, mit Hooligans –mit PSG-Fans und belgischen Clubs, das ist schon ein sehr trauriges Bild.
Vermutlich läuft die Aufarbeitung da in Frankreich auch noch. Gerade diese Verflechtung von anderen Fan-Gruppen, von lokalen Fan-Gruppen, die noch mit dabei waren, das macht es ja auch so schwierig, das irgendwie zu bewerten von außen. Gleichzeitig habe ich auch noch gehört, aber halt eben nur gehört, dass es immer Hörensagen, dass auch von den Ordnern im Stadion dann wiederum welche mit dabei gewesen sein sollen, die jetzt nicht ganz so, die eher so auf Seiten von Nizza mit Handgreiflichkeiten nicht so langsam waren und vielleicht sogar auch zum Fan-Umfeld Nizzas gehört haben sollen. Aber das sind eben alles sehr ungesicherte Informationen, bei denen man sehr vorsichtig sein muss. Deswegen möchte ich das ausdrücklich in ganz große Klammern setzen. Läuft da die Aufarbeitung? Gibt es da auch gegenteilige Informationen in Frankreich? Oder wie ist da der Stand?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, seit dem Wochenende hört man nichts mehr über dieses Thema, weil, glaube ich, es ist irgendwie über die Ermittlungen, was da rauskommt. Es dauert immer seine Zeit und man ist eher besorgt, wie gesagt, was zwischen Olympique Marseille und Frankfurt passiert. Ohne diese Vorkommnisse wäre Nizza vielleicht diese Sicherheitsvorkehrungen bei Marseille Frankfurt nicht so streng geworden. Nur zur Erinnerung, die Eintracht-Fans, ohne Ticket oder sogar mit Ticket, dürfen nicht in die Innenstadt, dürfen keine Eintracht-Trikots oder Schals tragen, nicht singen, nicht in Gruppen rumlaufen. Also ja, gleich lieber zu Hause bleiben.
Ja, also das hat mit freier Bewegungsfreiheit ja nichts mehr zu tun. Aber gut, das ist jetzt nochmal ein anderes Thema. Bevor ich das noch aufmache, ich weiß ja, dass wir dafür leider heute nicht mehr die Zeit haben. Danke ich dir, Alexi. Ich verabschiede dich an dieser Stelle schon. Dann schaffst du deinen Termin hoch. Ich bin ganz stolz. Das kommt mir im Rasenfunk nicht immer vor. Danke dir, Alexi, dass du mit dabei warst. Bis bald mal wieder.
Danke, meine Herren.
Mach's gut. Und wir machen hier an dieser Stelle weiter und springen aber nochmal zurück in die Premier League, denn auch Hendrik hat es heute eilig. Es ist heute ein einziges Termin, Tetris. Ich sag's euch, liebe Leute da draußen. Aber Hauptsache, wir kriegen die Ligatur dann trotzdem hin. Du möchtest mit uns, Hendrik, noch über jemanden sprechen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn jetzt richtig ausspreche. Haaland, der spielt bei dem anderen Club aus Manchester, wenn ich mich da richtig informiert habe. Was gibt's denn da zu sagen?
Ja, der ist –ich weiß nicht, ob man das in Deutschland mitbekommen hat –recht gut vorm Tor.
Woher kommt denn der?
Haaland ist bekanntlicherweise in der Manchester-Satire-Saison und ist eingeschlagen, wie das, glaube ich, weniger erwartet haben, mit schon zehn Premier League-Toren in sechs Spielen und zwei Toren in der Champions League beim 4-0 gegen Sevilla. Die Engländer werden ja schon schnell euphorisch, wenn es um Fußball geht und wenn es um Spieler geht, die in der Premier League, der natürlich besten Liga der Welt aus englischer Sicht, einschlagen. Aber das Echo auf Haaland ist noch mal euphorischer, als man das kennt, weil, glaube ich, insgesamt die Deutung ist, dass mit Haaland Manchester City einfach endgültig unbesiegbar ist. Und eigentlich alle Beobachter erstaunt und verblüfft darüber sind, wie gut er hier angekommen ist. Und wie schnell er sich integriert hat und nicht mehr aus dieser Mannschaft wegzudenken ist. Wahrscheinlich wird jegliche Torekorde brechen. Es gab vor der Saison den Super Cup, den Community-Sheet gegen Liverpool. Liverpool 3-1 gewonnen hat, wirkt auch schon wieder sehr lange her. Das war Harlands Pflichtspiel-Debüt. Das gilt hier als Pflichtspiel. Da hat er ein ziemlich schwaches Spiel gehabt. Also war kaum am Ball. Kevin de Preune hat auch mal so eine frustrierte Handbewegung in seine Richtung gemacht und hat dann auch zwei große Chancen vergeben. Genau, da war dann aber schon so ein bisschen das Medienecho. Man muss mal schauen, ob das mit Pep Guardiola zusammenpasst. Diese vertikalen Läufe hinter die Abwehr, die Harland aushält. Das ist ja auch gar nicht Guardiola-Spiel, der auf Ball besitzt und den Ball halten und viele Pässe usw. Das zeigt, dass es alles Zeit braucht, bis sich Harland integriert. Dann hat sich aber in Rekordgeschwindigkeit erwiesen, dass es überhaupt keine Zeit braucht, sondern dass sich Harland sofort integriert hat. Das Interessante ist, dass Manchester City noch einmal eine komplett andere Dimension im Spiel hat, weil es bislang schon so war, dass City auf Ball gesetzt hat. Der Ball hat so lange vor dem 16er kreisen lassen, bis eine Lücke entstanden ist. Dann gab es auf den Steilpass Richtung Grundlinie und von dort oder der Ball zurückgelegt. In der Mitte hat dann jemand eingeschoben. Das ist das klassische Manchester City Tor unter Guardiola. 100.000 Mal gesehen und wird man auch in dieser Saison noch oft sehen. Aber durch Harland hat man jetzt plötzlich doch die Möglichkeit, auch vertikale Bälle hinter die gegnerische Abwehr zu spielen, die Harland dann aufnimmt und sich auch –das haben wir jetzt auch schon in mehreren Spielen gesehen –sich gegen mehrere Spieler durchsetzen, die abschütteln und den Ball einschieben. Man hat plötzlich auch einen Spieler vorne drin, der Kopfballstark ist. Das ist für Manchester City auch neu, weil die Mannschaft ja sonst, typische Guardiola-Spieler, ja eher klein bis mittelgroß sind. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was vor allem den Rest der Premier League beunruhigen sollte. Nicht, dass man jetzt noch jemanden hat, der diese typischen Guardiola-Spielzüge abschließen kann, sondern dass man durch Harland eben nochmal ganz andere Dimensionen im Spiel hat. Und Harland ist der Grund dafür, dass Manchester City, muss man sagen, mal wieder als Top-Favoriten in den Champions-League-Saison geht. Da muss man dann mal schauen, weil meiner Meinung nach es am Personal auch schon in den vergangenen Jahren nicht unbedingt gescheitert ist, sondern dann oft an den berühmten Gedankenspielen von Guardiola. Also ich finde diese Gleichung zu sagen, jetzt hat man Harland, jetzt gewinnen sie auch die Champions League, finde ich zu einfach. Also das muss man mal schauen. Aber ich kann in der Premier League mir nicht vorstellen, so wie sich Harland integriert hat, dass es da einen Verein gibt, der auch nur annähernd gefährlich werden kann. Famous Last Words möglicherweise, aber ich finde das sehr beeindruckend. Und jetzt gibt es ja morgen auch die Reunion mit Dortmund, wenn die hier spielen in der Champions League. Ich weiß nicht, wie in Dortmund der Blick auf dieses Spiel ist, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Harland da natürlich auch wieder –Angespannt, würde ich sagen. Angespannt, ja, zu Recht. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass Harland natürlich auch da wieder eine zentrale Rolle spielen wird. Und wie gesagt, wie einfach er sich hier eingefügt hat, das verblüfft dir tatsächlich alle Beobachter, weil es ja auch so ein bisschen auf diese These ist, dass es in der Premier League halt immer dauert, weil die Premier League –und das habe ich vorhin schon gesagt –aus englischer Sicht die beste Liga der Welt und die stärkste. Und selbst Superstars haben es hier schwierig, weil die Premier League halt so ein hohes Niveau usw. usf. Aber Harland ist halt der Beweis dafür, dass wenn man halt die Klasse hat, dann kommt man hier natürlich auch sofort zurecht.
Ja, das ist dringend das neue Narrativ, das die Premier League braucht. Spieler aus der Bundesliga, die brauchen keine Anlaufzeit. Das ist einfach daran.
Ja, das ist natürlich Harland ein spezieller Fall, ist klar. Akkanji hat ja auch gespielt gegen Sevilla. Pascal Groß ist aber auch… Harland ist der spektakulärste Transfer des Sommers gewesen, auch wenn es ein vergleichsweise günstigeres Transfer war. Wenn man sieht, was Chelsea für Coquerea ausgegeben hat oder Manchester United für Anthony. Es ist erstaunlich, dass man Harland vergleichsweise wenig Geld bekommt, aber es ist der spektakulärste Transfer des Sommers gewesen. Und das löst er halt auch total ein.
Also 10 Tore und ein Assist in sechs Pflichtspielen, das ist jetzt nicht so schlecht. Und es ist völlig gerechtfertigt, dass wir ihn hier feiern. Gleichzeitig sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle drei, die wir jetzt noch verblieben sind in dieser Sendung, uns einig. Jetzt erstmal gucken, wie das mit Verletzungen wird, wie das über diese Saison hinweggeht. Bisher war Harland, wenn er spielen konnte, immer toll. Aber er konnte eben leider nicht immer spielen. Deswegen das kurze Fragezeichen noch dahinter. Aber das werden wir ganz entspannt beobachten. Hendrik, ich danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Hendrik Buchheister, danke dir und bis bald mal wieder im Rasenfunk.
Ja, sehr gern.
Und jetzt sind es nur noch wir beide, Christian. Last Man Standing. Das war heute mal eine wirklich interessante Ligatur. Irgendwie mit diesen ganzen verschiedenen Konstellationen. Wir haben noch zwei Themen, über die wir sprechen wollen. Zum einen haben wir Napoli jetzt schon mal abgehandelt. Jetzt willst du uns ein bisschen was von Atalanta erzählen, worauf ich mich schon sehr freue.
Ja, ich würde lieber, zieh mal erstmal Juwe vor. Ja, weil es passt ganz gut, so als wir vorhin PSG und Liverpool so ein bisschen haben, Fragezeichen. Und vor allen Dingen, deswegen finde ich, passt es am besten, weil es die Aktualität wunderbar aufnimmt. Denn am Wochenende ging es in der Serie A. Ja, ziemlich rund. Juwe Salernitana Heimspiel, Juwe liegt 0-2 zurück, gleicht in der Nachspielzeit zum 2-2 aus und macht in der 96. auch noch das 3-2, was aber vom VAR zurückgenommen wurde, was bis heute kaum jemand versteht. Also es geht darum, es war eine Eckball-Situation, Milik Bergkopf und Bonucci standen im Abseits, keine Frage, aber hat halt in keinster Weise eingegriffen. Also hat weder ein Gegenspieler irgendwie bedrängt, noch auch dem Torhüter irgendwas getan sozusagen. Und dann dazu kam sogar, also das ist wirklich ein riesenpolitisches Thema, heute kamen sogar noch Aufnahmen, die standen dem VAR nicht zur Verfügung, dass sogar nach dem Eckball, womöglich Candreva, auch noch Bonucci im Spiel gehalten haben könnte. Aber diese Aufnahmen hatte der VAR nicht zur Verfügung. Da hat sich heute die Schiedsrichtervereinigung in Italien gemeint, ja es tut uns leid, aber das Bild stand nicht zur Verfügung. Also Riesentohu Wabohu.
Aber was heißt im Spiel gehalten? Das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht verstanden.
Also es war eine Eckball-Situation. Der Ball kommt rein, Millic am kurzen Pfosten, köpft und Bonucci steht da im Abseits, aber aus dem Spielausschnitt, den man hatte von der Kamera. Von der anderen Seite hat man gesehen, dass Candreva, der stand bei der Ecke, sozusagen vorne an der kurzen…
Ach so, weil da noch der Salernitana-Spieler stand.
Genau.
Stimmt, das habe ich gesehen und das war deutlich. Also der hatte so um einen Meter oder so weiter aufgehoben.
Könnte sein, denn man ist schwer zu beurteilen. Fakt ist, dass man einfach die Frage stellen muss, worum hatte der Vardis das? Nicht zur Verfügung. Das ist die erste große Frage. Ja, also es ging wahnsinnig los. Es gab Tumulte danach, 47 Personen waren auf dem Spielfeld.
Ich finde das auch fantastisch, dass das dann irgendjemand nachgefällt hat.
Die italienische Presse, da wird gezahlt, genau. Es ging total ab. Allegri hat rot gesehen, Quadrado hat rot gesehen, Fazio hat rot gesehen, Milik auch irgendwie. Das trifft die Geschichte auch perfekt. Milik hat für das Trikot ausziehen, für das Tor. Gelb-rot gesehen, weil er vor schon gelb hatte. Im Prinzip ist er jetzt vom Platz gegangen für ein Tor, dass ihm dann nicht zugesprochen wurde, dass ihm aber eigentlich hätte zugesprochen werden müssen. Riesengeschichte war nicht die einzige Szene an dem Wochenende. Letze gab es auch krasse Fehler des Wars, auch bei Fiorentina auch. Es war ein ganz unglückliches Wochenende aus der Sicht. Aber wir wollen ja ein bisschen über Juve sprechen. Ja, in dem Fall hätte Juve die zwei Punkte dazu bekommen müssen. Dann wären sie jetzt auch bei 12, was ja gar nicht schlecht aussieht. Aber Fakt ist, sie haben das Spiel jetzt halt doch nicht gewonnen. Sie sind zwar noch ungeschlagen, aber haben nach sechs Spieltagen auch erst zwei Siege. Dazu noch die Niederlage in der Champions League. Also Juve, die vielen Fragezeichen, die es bei Allegri in der vergangenen Saison gab, sind weiterhin da. Klar kann man Allegri jetzt zu gut erhalten. Er hat Boban nicht, der verletzt ist. Er hat Kieser nicht, der erst im Winter zurückkommt. Er hatte die Maria nur tröpfchenweise in dieser Startphase. Da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Extrem wichtige Spieler. Aber es ist immer noch der Eindruck verfestigt, dass Juve, die Spieleidee mit Ball, nicht wirklich ausgereift ist. Es gab schon Beispiele in der Saison. Wlauowitsch hatte auch einen guten Start, hat zwei sehr schöne Freistoßtore geschossen, auch am ersten Spieltag getroffen. Aber immer wieder auch Spiele, wo Wlauowitsch kaum ins Spiel eingebunden wird. Du hast einen Stürmer, der das vorne abliefern kann, wenn er die Bälle kriegt. Aber er kriegt phasenweise sehr wenige Bälle. Es gab am zweiten Spieltag Juve Gas spielt bei Sampdoria. Also nicht der große Name. Wlauowitsch 90 Minuten auf dem Platz, neun Ballkontakte. Das für eine Mannschaft, die von sich selbst gesagt hat, auch Allegri, Locatelli, die spieler im Sommer, wir wollen aktiver werden, wir wollen dominanter werden. Da fehlt sehr oft die Struktur. Im Moment hilft Milik an seiner Seite. Milik ist sehr gut reingekommen. Zweimal getroffen, hat jetzt auch das dritte Mal getroffen. Die zwei funktionieren auch gut. Milik ist einer, der mitspielt, der auch ein bisschen Räume öffnet für Wlauowitsch. Aber wie gesagt, sie kriegen Wlauowitsch ganz oft nicht ins Spiel rein. Und das zeigt eben, dass sie immer noch strukturelle Probleme haben. Wir hatten Spalletti vorhin. Das ist ganz interessant. Spalletti und Allegri waren beide zwei Jahre raus, bevor sie im vergangenen Sommer wieder quasi reingekommen sind. Spalletti zu Neapel, Allegri zu Juve. Und ich finde, da siehst du einen Unterschied, wie Tag und Nacht. Bei Spalletti, der war zwar zwei Jahre raus, aber du weißt, das ist ein moderner …Der ist drangeblieben. Der ist drangeblieben. Der weiß, was er will. Er hat sich weiterentwickelt. Bei Allegri habe ich das Gefühl, er ist vor ein paar Jahren stehen geblieben. Da kommen immer noch kommunikativ die Parolen, es geht darum, zu gewinnen. Entschieden werden die Spielzeiten im März. Alles solche Geschichten. Nur Fakt ist, letztes Jahr im März war Juve schon weit weg. Und plus, er sagt, es geht nur ums Gewinnen. Jetzt haben wir ein Siebensaisonspiel und sie haben nur zwei davon gewonnen. Dann ziehen seine kommunikativen Dinge auch nicht wirklich. Er hat Barredes jetzt noch bekommen aus Paris. Der war gleich wichtig. Der wird auch eine wichtige Rolle im Mittelfeld-Centrum übernehmen. Das war der Spielertyp, der ihnen gefällt hat. Aber mir reicht es da nicht auch an Ausreden, dass dir Chiesa fehlt, dass dir Bogba fehlt, dass dir die Maria fehlt. Es gibt immer teilweise Halbzeiten vor Vorletzerm Spieltag. Juve in Florenz, da kam kein einziger Torabschluss in der zweiten Halbzeit von Juve. Das ist phasenweise viel zu dünn für das Material, was er einfach zur Verfügung hat, auch wenn die Chiesas und Bogbas und die Marias noch fehlen.
Vor allem, weil das ist doch schon auch ein älteres Thema bei Allegri, dass er so kontrolliert spielende Mannschaften hatte, die aber auch gerne die Kontrolle vor allem der Eigenhälfte ausgeübt haben, oder?
Ja, und wie gesagt, das ist ja seine Kommunikation auch immer noch, das meinte ich, deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, er ist ein bisschen stehen geblieben, weil er gesagt hat, wir müssen nicht schön spielen, wir müssen einfach nur erfolgreich spielen. Das funktioniert, solange du erfolgreich spielst. Aber wenn du dir die letzte Saison hernimmst, er war der erste Trainer, in dem Juve seit zehn Jahren keinen einzelnen Titel gewonnen hat. Er war schon lange aus der Meisterentscheidung weg, bevor sie am Ende noch mal ein bisschen rangekommen sind, aber da waren sie schon lange weg. Und jetzt, wie gesagt, wenn wir im Allegri-Stil reden, sieben Spiele, zwei Siege. Also Saisonspiele, zwei Siege. Das ist dann zu wenig, um das zu befeuern, mit, ja gut, wir stehen kontrolliert, brauchen wenig und machen dann unsere Buden. Dafür hat sich auch meiner Meinung nach der Fußball zu sehr weiterentwickelt, dieses Lang auf Null, Null oder Lang die Null halten, das funktioniert auch in den wenigsten Weisen. Sehen wir ja auch Guardiola, andere große Trainer, die stellen ihr Spiel ja auch komplett anders auf. Und bei ihm, wie gesagt, ist das, manifiziert sich oft das Gefühl, dass er da ein bisschen hängen geblieben ist. Und deswegen, für mich ist das der Riesenfaktor in dieser Juwe-Saison. Juwe wird sich, wenn die Verletzten zurückkommen, dann ist da einfach wahnsinnig viel individuelle Qualität da. Das ist auch gesehen an die Maria, die paar Spiele, die er hatte, wie wichtig der schon war. Nicht nur im letzten Drittel, sondern auch im Spielaufbau. Der bietet dir Lösungen, hilft dir. Das ist sehr, sehr viel individuelle Qualität. Aber für mich steht und fällt die Saison mit Allegri. Ob es Allegri dann schafft, dem wirklich auch eine Identität mit Ball zu geben, davon ist im Moment immer noch entfernt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt auf das Heimspiel jetzt gegen Benfica.
Das ist das ganz klare Clou-Spiel. Da auch noch ein Satz dazu. Das war auch so eine Allegri-Nummer, wo man sich hat fragen können, vor dem ersten Saisonspiel Champions League in Paris stellt sich Allegri hin und sagt, das entscheidende wichtige Spiel sind die Spiele gegen Benfica. Also vor dem Auftakt. Im Prinzip hat er ihnen auch schon ein Alibi gegeben. In Paris, das ist eh nicht unsere Kragenweite. Dann sind sie früh 2-0 zurück, machen es dann eigentlich gut. Kommen in der zweiten Hälfte auch gut rein. Du siehst ja, die Mannschaft hat Potenzial. Aber man kann schon auch von einem so großen Trainer, erfahrenen Trainer, die Frage stellen, warum gibt es da der Mannschaft so ein Alibi? Und jetzt, wie du sagst, jetzt ist Benfica und das sind logischerweise die entscheidenden Spiele für die Gruppenphase für Juve.
Hatte er dann doch recht. Aber gut, Self-fulfilling prophecy vielleicht ein bisschen. Okay, das ist die Situation bei Juve. Und was haben wir bei Atalanta? Du hast geschrieben, das neue Atalanta. Was ist denn alles neu bei Atalanta?
Ja, also erstens Atalanta, Punkt gleich mit Napoli und Milan an der Spitze. Das war auch nicht unbedingt zu erwarten nach der letzten Saison, weil da ist doch ein bisschen was von diesem Atalanta-Zauber verflogen, der ja einige Jahre angehalten hat. Ich finde, also klar, ergebnistechnisch keine Frage. Sie haben es nicht mal geschafft, sich international zu qualifizieren. Deswegen ganz klar. Aber sie waren in der letzten Saison auch nicht schlecht. Also was ihnen gefehlt hat, war oft im letzten Drittel. Sie haben es immer wieder geschafft, Chancen zu kreieren, viele Leute in die gefährliche Zone zu bringen. Aber dann hat es einfach daran gehapert, dass sie ihre Tore nicht gemacht haben. Das lag daran, dass Zapata lange verletzt war. Allgemein war da so ein bisschen der Wurm drin. Am Ende standen sie da ohne Europapokal teilnehmen. Deswegen war jetzt im Sommer schon die Frage, was passiert jetzt mit Atalanta? Gasparini gab es so ein paar Aussagen. Da war ja auch der Eigentümerwechsel. Da ist jetzt auch eine amerikanische Gruppe dahinter. Gasparini meinte, wir müssen mal reden und schauen, ob das noch passt. Irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, das Zauber ist verflogen. Sie haben sich jetzt im Sommer verjüngt. Das war meiner Meinung nach ein sehr guter Schritt. Sie haben Heulund vorne, einen jungen Mann aus Graz, für den sie tief in die Tasche gegriffen haben. Ein junger dänischer Stürmer, der jetzt auch schon einmal getroffen hat. Sie haben Lukman geholt, den man aus Leipzig noch kennt. Sie haben Ederson geholt von der Salernitana im zentralen Mittelfeld, 23 Jahre jung. Sie haben Soppi geholt auf außen, 20 Jahre jung. Und hinten Orcoli, ein aufstreibender, junger italienischer Innenverteidiger, der ausgeliehen war in Kremonese, der jetzt wieder gekommen ist. Also frisches Blut. Und das tut ihnen insofern gut, weil der Stil ist weiterhin sehr aktiv, sehr physisch. Da wird marschiert, da wird Tempo gemacht. Aber sie sind defensiv viel strukturierter geworden. Also früher, wahrscheinlich viele, die sich jetzt noch an Atalanta erinnern, da war oft Krawall, also im positiven Sinne. Da war offensiv wahnsinnig viel los. Sie haben auch Räume gelassen. Und das ist jetzt in dieser Startphase, haben sie viel kontrollierter. Sie brauchen im Moment wenig. Sie hatten jetzt am Wochenende Kremonese, haben lang 1-0 geführt. Wenn sie das Spiel gewonnen hätten, dann wären sie jetzt bei 16 Punkten. Dann hätten sie nur das eine Unentschieden gegen Milan, das ziemlich beeindruckend war. Sie haben zwar noch in dem Fall später einen Ausgleich bekommen, aber sie hatten schon Spiele in der Saison, wo sie kontrolliert gespielt haben und dann irgendwann ihr Tor gemacht haben und dann die Spiele auch die meisten bisher gewonnen haben. Und wenn deswegen, wie gesagt, dazu kommt, diese Defensive, ein bisschen mehr Ausgeglichenheit, dazu frischer Wind, der da ist und weiterhin die Abläufe von Gasperini, die ja weiterhin da sind, also die Mannschaft weiß ja, was sie zu tun hat, finde ich einen spannenden Ansatz vor allen Dingen. Und das könnte halt ein entscheidender Punkt sein. Sie sind jetzt halt auch die einzigen aus diesen italienischen Top-Clubs, die nicht die Doppelbelastung haben. Wenn man sich gerade in dieser Startphase angeschaut hat, eine englische Woche nach der anderen, bei den großen teilweise schon einige muskuläre Verletzungen in Italien, wirklich auffällig. Also man hat gemerkt, dass dieser –was man in Italien nicht unterschätzen darf –die Saison ging eine Woche früher los, als gewohnt. Hat aber auch lang gedauert für viele Spieler mit Nationalmannschaft. Man hat jetzt schon mal gemerkt, das haben auch einige Serie-A-Trainer schon angesprochen, muskuläre Geschichten könnten gefährlich werden. Und du hast bei allen Top-Teams jetzt schon –dabei sind Schlüsselspieler, die fehlen –und Atalanta sind die einzigen, die sich erst mal Woche für Woche –oder logisch in der Englischen Serie –nicht diese Doppelbelastung haben. Und dadurch, dass sie weiterhin einen sehr physisch intensiven Stil spielen, sehr körperlich stark sind, hat Milan sehr zu spüren bekommen bei dem 1-1 vor Kurzem. Also Atalanta wegschieben ist weiterhin nicht so einfach, könnte jetzt schon ein Faktor werden, der ihnen zugutekommt. Dementsprechend bin ich sehr gespannt. Ich muss sagen, mich hat es überrascht, dass sie, weil sie oft auch ein bisschen Spätstarter waren, jetzt sind sie gleich schon da. Schauen, wie sich das weiterhin entwickelt. Gasperini hatte auch noch im Spätsommer Gemeinsam. Eigentlich ist das nicht die Mannschaft, die ich wollte. Ich hatte schon ein bisschen andere Ideen gehabt. Hat so ein bisschen vor sich hin gemurmelt, sage ich mal. Aber Fakt ist, jetzt ist er mittendrin. Er hat auch noch Stürmer bekommen, er hat Heulund bekommen, Luckmann bekommen. Das war auch immer so ein Thema. Er hat gesagt, seit zwei Jahren rede ich einfach ein, wir brauchen Stürmer, wir brauchen Stürmer. Jetzt hat er sie bekommen. Die haben auch beide gleich schon gut eingeschlagen. Also, spannendes Projekt. Schauen, ob Atalanta es schafft, da auch vorne dran zu bleiben.
Aber absolut. Und ich bin so dankbar, dass du hier bist, Christian, und dass ich hier immer Experten habe. Denn bei der Serie A ist es wirklich unmöglich, die Transfers zu bewerten. Atalanta hatte 64 Zugänge und 63 Abgänge. Woher soll ich erkennen, wer in diesem Wust aus Leyen vielleicht dann doch irgendwas kann? Ich habe keine Chance. Es ist einfach absolut bezahlt.
Ja, das ist ein großes Thema. Es sind ja auch ein paar, so wie einer wie Remo Freuler, der in die Premier League gewechselt ist. Also, auch logisch Identifikationsfigur, wichtiger Figur, die weg sind. Aber eben wie gesagt, sie sind jünger geworden. Und im Moment, eine Einnahme müssen wir noch nennen, Coop Miners. Der Niederländer, der letzte Saison auch schon da war.
Schon vier Tore gemacht.
Ja, herausragenden Saisonstart. Nicht nur aufgrund seiner Tore, da wirklich im zentralen Mittelfeld, da war ja ewig diese Freuler, der Ruhn, das war so das Tour, das der Land auch getragen hat. Die anderen haben Krawall gemacht, sage ich mal, im positiven Sinne, und sie haben da im Zentrum das Zentrum zugemacht. Coop Miners ist jetzt da in die Rolle mit der Ruhn perfekt rein, hat da auch noch diesen sehr, sehr guten Abschluss aus der Distanz, der schon ein paar Mal zum Tragen kam, bringt diese Füße mit, verkörpert jetzt eigentlich auch diesen Atalanta-Stil, sehr, sehr gut von Gasperini. Also ja, sehr guter Start und eben wie gesagt, sie haben die Doppelbelastung nicht.
Mensch, die Serie A, es verspricht wieder eine spannende Saison zu werden. Ich danke dir ganz herzlich, das war Christian Bernhard. Danke, dass du hier ins Rasenfunk-Hauptstudio gekommen bist. Als hätten wir neben Studios. Und ihr hört jetzt noch hier gleich das, was ich mit Fabian Pakulat zu La Liga besprochen habe. Viel Spaß damit und bitte. Jetzt wollen wir über La Liga sprechen und ich freue mich, dass Fabian Pakulat hier ist, der Ed Rosengartler. Hallo Fabian. Morgen, Abend. Es ist ja alles zeitrein im Podcastbereich. Hast du die Sommerpause gut hinter dich gebracht?
War in Deutschland, Italien, Baskenland und jetzt wieder zurück in Malaga.
Das hat sich ehrlich gesagt sogar bis auf den letzten Ort hin nach Urlaub angehört. Aber gut, das ist eben dein Leben. Ein Leben in Sonnenschein. Wir wollen über La Liga sprechen. 5 Spieltage sind bereits absolviert. Ein paar Dinge haben die Hörerinnen und Hörer bestimmt mitbekommen. Also es wird ihnen jetzt nicht entgangen sein, dass ein gewisser Robert Lewandowski bei Barca spielt. Zum Beispiel. Aber ein paar Dinge vielleicht nicht so. Und vielleicht fangen wir damit gleich mal an. Du hast drei Themen mitgebracht. Und eines davon betrifft die aktuelle Überraschungsmannschaft. Und das ist Ossasuna. Warum liegen die auf Tabellenplatz 4? Ja, okay, ist jetzt erstmal die Tabelle noch 5 Spieltagen. Aber wie konnten die so erfolgreich in die Saison starten?
Also sie haben wirklich in den letzten Jahren kontinuierlich gute Arbeit geleistet und haben einen Trainer, den ich für sehr, sehr interessant halte und sehr gut. Der heißt Yagova Arasate, ist ein Baske. Ossasuna ist ja eigentlich das Team aus Pamplona. Ossasuna ist quasi der baskische Name dafür. Und ja, ist eigentlich eher immer so ein kleiner Verein gewesen, so ein typischer Verein, der halt immer mal so zwischen erster und zweiter Liga hin und her pendelt. Sie haben jetzt aber seit, ich glaube, jetzt im zweiten Jahr ein komplett neues Stadion, ein richtig schönes Schmuckkästchen, das natürlich immer voll ist. Und ja, sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft, in den letzten Jahren gute Spieler zu halten. Am Trainer haben sie auch ziemlich lange festgehalten. Und im Moment funktioniert das richtig gut. Wie gesagt, sehr, sehr überraschend gut, dass es so auf Takt mit vier Siegen, einer Niederlage nach fünf Spielen.
Sie haben unter anderem gegen Sevilla mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Kann man denn am Beispiel Ossasuna etwas lernen, wie man es schaffen kann, in der La Liga, sich so langsam nach oben zu arbeiten? Also wie gesagt, natürlich müssen wir die Klammer drum machen, Fünfter Spieltag und so weiter. Und es kann sein, dass das jetzt nur eine Momentaufnahme ist. Aber die Dinge, die du angesprochen hast, das neue Stadion, das Festhalten an einem interessanten Trainer, das scheint mir ja schon etwas zu sein, was auf Längerfristigkeit hindeutet.
Ja, vielleicht kann man sogar ein bisschen vergleichen mit dem ST Freiburg in Deutschland. Natürlich ist Freiburg da nochmal ein Stück weiter voraus. Die sind ja mit Christian Streich schon länger ziemlich erfolgreich unterwegs. Haben wir aber auch jetzt mit dem neuen Stadion sich natürlich nochmal ein finanzielles extra Polster geschaffen. Da kommt natürlich auch, obwohl das natürlich zum ersten Mal eine Ausgabe ist, aber es kommt natürlich jetzt auch viel Geld rein, kontinuierlich. Und sie schaffen es tatsächlich auch so, wie gesagt, eine gute Stimmung im Team zu haben, dass viele Spieler vielleicht auch bei anderen Vereinen nicht so gut spielen würden wie vielleicht in Ostersuna. Es ist relativ ruhig, sie können in Ruhe arbeiten. Und wie gesagt, haben einen hervorragenden Trainer. Und das passt im Moment wirklich sehr gut zusammen.
Und geht damit auch ein eigener Spielstil einher? Gibt es Dinge, die Ostersuna auch da anders macht als andere Teams?
Also Ostersuna war in den letzten Jahren eigentlich eher bekannt, oder sagen wir mal, vor diesem Trainerbeginn sehr einsatzfreudig immer zu sein, aber eher so, was die Defensivarbeit anbelangt. Und da war spielerisch jetzt eigentlich nicht so der lecker Bissen. Aber sie haben inzwischen auch dort sich stark verbessert. Haben da wirklich ein paar gute Spieler mit Jimmy Avila vorne in Argentinien. Ein sehr interessanten Stürmer, den kennen vielleicht noch einige aus diversen Strangen Interviews. Er war mal ein sehr armer Schlucker in Argentinien. War da auch auf der Verbrecherschiene so ein bisschen unterwegs. Hatte eine schwere Verletzung und hat es aber dann trotzdem geschafft, jetzt Profi zu werden. Und hat viele Angebote übrigens auch von Top-Clubs in den letzten Jahren. Hat sich aber entschieden, bei Osasuna zu bleiben, weil sie ihm eben die Chance gegeben haben. Und er zahlt das im Moment mit sehr starken Leistungen zurück und eben auch Toren.
War Jemi Avila der Spieler, der mit 13 Jahren sich sein erstes Tattoo selbst gestochen hat?
Ich glaube, das war er, ja. Und hat auch dann eben Kollegen über den Tisch gezogen und so weiter. War halt hartes Überleben in Argentinien. Er hat auch selbst gesagt, dass er da viel Mist gebaut hat. Und naja, er ist jetzt sehr dankbar, sagen wir mal, über seine zweite Chance im Leben. Und ja, wie gesagt, hat jetzt bevorzugt, bei diesem Club zu bleiben, weil er dort wirklich befreit arbeiten kann. Und er möchte dem Club auch ein bisschen was zurückzahlen, dass er eben dieses Vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen hat vom Verein.
Ich habe übrigens untertrieben. Es war schon mit zehn Jahren das erste Vertrauen. Ich werde mal ein Porträt dazu verlinken. Er hat sich übrigens das Wappen von Rosario damals tätowiert. Also da der Fußballbezug auch da sehr, sehr interessantes. Der war erst einmal bei ESPN erschienen. Da habe ich mich jetzt eben gerade noch dran erinnert. Also da hat man einen Charakter. Wie wird das denn eigentlich in La Liga dann betrachtet? Ist das eine Willkommene Abwechslung von den immer gleichen Geschichten? Oder immer gleich ist jetzt ein bisschen zu viel. Da widersprechen auch die Ligatouren der letzten Saison. Aber es konzentriert sich ja logisch, weil sie dann doch immer auf die großen zweieinhalb, vielleicht auch großen drei. Ist das ein größeres Thema?
Noch nicht. Und ich denke auch, es wird relativ schnell wieder verfliegen, weil ich auch davon ausgehe, dass Osasuna sich dort nicht lange halten wird. Es gibt immer dann so kurze Momentaufnahmen. Da wird man kurz gefeiert und da bekommt man kurz Medienaufmerksamkeit. Aber morgen wird schon wieder alles von basa, unreal und den üblichen Verdächtigen übertüncht werden. Aber für Osasuna ist es auf jeden Fall eine schöne Momentaufnahme. Und wenn sie es tatsächlich mittel- oder langfristig schaffen sollten, dann eben vielleicht so etwas aufzubauen wie der SC Freiburg in Deutschland, dann wird es mit Sicherheit auch mit der Medienaufmerksamkeit anders sein. Aber im Moment denke ich mal eher, es ist eine kurzfristige Lupe, die da über Osasuna, über Pamplona gelegt worden ist. Aber die wird auch schnell wieder verschwinden, sobald der sportliche Erfolg ausbleibt.
Umso schöner, dass wir das jetzt auch hier an dieser Stelle getan haben. Und auch das zweite Thema, das du mitgebracht hast, lenkt den Blick noch nicht auf die großen zwei, nur indirekt. Denn du hast mir geschrieben, und ich zitiere hier, das möchte ich betonen, Betis ist die neue Nummer 1 in Spanien. Bitte was?
Die neue Nummer 1 der normalen Teams, sage ich jetzt mal in Ad-Filmzeichen. Denn nach Real Madrid und Barcelona kommt ja lange Zeit nichts. Atletico Madrid wollen wir da vielleicht, kann man eventuell noch mit reinrechnen, aber auch die haben nicht das hohe Standing, wie diese ersten Bayern-Vereine. Und dementsprechend ist quasi Real Betis im Moment die erste Mannschaft in Spanien, der nicht galaktischen. Es liegt auch hier, glaube ich, wieder vor allen Dingen am Trainer, an Manuel Pellegrini, der dort auch jetzt schon ein paar Jahre kontinuierlich arbeiten kann. Er hat sich da ein Team zusammengestückelt, das wirklich Freude macht. Und er hatte trotz so großen Problemen in der Vorbereitung. Betis hatte nämlich bis zum Transfermarkt-Schluss Probleme, drei oder vier Neuzugänge einzuschreiben. Das war in Spanien ein riesen Theater, bis alle Vereine es geschafft haben, aufgrund des Celery Cups alle Spiele einschreiben zu können. Dementsprechend war Betis, glaube ich, auch die ersten vier Spiele nur mit dem Dreiviertel-Kader unterwegs. Aber sie schaffen es eben auch innerhalb der Mannschaft, eine tolle Stimmung zu haben. Sie haben da so ein paar Vögel in den Reihen, wie zum Beispiel Joaquín, der ist jetzt schon 41, aber der ist einfach… 41, ja. Er spielt auch nicht mehr viel. Aber er ist einfach dafür da, in der Mannschaft Stimmung zu haben. Man sieht das auch immer in den Social-Media-Kanälen, die Betis auch sehr einzigartig betreibt, wie das Team miteinander umgeht, wie sie zusammen lachen, feiern, essen, sonst irgendwas machen. Und natürlich, wenn dann gleichzeitig der sportliche Erfolg auch da ist, dann geht das natürlich hervorragend. Und Pellegrini ist tatsächlich auch ein Übungsleiter, der in schwierigen Situationen es schafft, die Spieler zu schützen. Er war ja mal bei unserem FC Malaga-Trainer, als wir Champions League gespielt haben und ins Viertelfinale damals eingezogen sind. Und auch dort gab es große Probleme. Der Schalke hat die Spieler monatelang nicht bezahlt. Und Pellegrini hat das trotzdem geschafft, die Mannschaft zusammenzuhalten, eine gute Stimmung zu erzeugen. Und gemeinsam haben sie dann quasi eine gewisse Stärke entwickelt aus dieser schwierigen Situation. Ja, und das gelingt ihnen bei Bettis auch wunderbar. Und sie haben wirklich auch sehr, sehr gute Einzelspiele in ihren Reihen. Also ich denke mal, Bettis ist für mich, war ja vor der Saison schon unter den Top-6 auf jeden Fall gesetzt. Und wer weiß, vielleicht klappt es dieses Jahr sogar mit der Champions League.
Hey, wenn ich da jetzt mal so oberflächlich drauf gucke, dann sehe ich allerdings sehr viele erfahrene Spieler, würde ich es jetzt mal nennen. Also William Carvalho, 30 Jahre, Sabali, 29, Guido Rodriguez, Iglesias, 29, 28, 31, Seato Canales und so weiter und so fort. Also relativ wenige junge Spieler. Hat das jetzt auch damit zu tun, dass ich hier gerade in der Ansicht bin, wo nach Spielzeit und nach bisheriger Leistung sortiert wird und da manche noch nicht eingeschrieben waren? Oder ist das noch ein Charakteristikum von Bettis?
Also es gibt natürlich schon noch ein paar Junge, die vielleicht noch nicht eingeschrieben waren, wie zum Beispiel Luis Henrique, der Brasilianer, der am Anfang erst so kam, der jetzt glaube ich erst dieses Wochenende sein erstes Spiel gemacht hat.
Gleich ein Assist?
Ja, genau, gleich ein Assist. Aber du hast schon recht, es sind sehr viele Erfahrungen da, aber es gibt auch ein paar Junge. Es gibt zum Beispiel Rodri aus dem offensiven Mittelfeld von Bettis, der das Tor glaube ich jetzt auch gemacht hat am Wochenende, der viel Spielzeit bekommt. Und ja, da stimmt einfach die Mischung im Moment, muss ich sagen, sehr gut. Und natürlich ist es einfacher, erfahrene Spiele zu führen, auch durch so schwierige Zeiten, die dann vielleicht auf die paar Jungen noch mitnehmen. Und wie gesagt, da ist was Schönes zusammengewachsen bei Sevilla.
Wie sieht der Fußball aus? Man kann ja Pellegrini-Mannschaften immer ganz gut angucken, wenn ich mich da richtig erinnere. Doch, absolut.
Es ist eine kontrollierte Offensive. Es ist kein Hauruck-Fußball, wir gehen nach vorne und pressen ganz, ganz vorne drauf, sondern es ist eher schon so ein bisschen abwarten, dann aber bei Ballgewinn wird natürlich auch extrem schnell umgeschaltet und da haben sie natürlich schon auch Spieler, wie zum Beispiel Canales, den du angesprochen hast, oder Nabil Fekir, die dann eben dann den tödlichen Pass spielen können. Und vorne haben sie eigentlich mit Borja Iglesias, im Moment einen der besten Spanischen Stürmer. Der trifft zumindest in den letzten Monaten, wie er lustig ist. Mit Juanmi haben sie jetzt einen, der sich leider verletzt hat, schwer. Der hat in den letzten Jahren auch vor allen Dingen mit seiner Schnelligkeit viele gefährliche Situationen rausgespielt. William José ist da, der auch jetzt eingeschrieben werden konnte. Der hat aber jetzt in der Europa League getroffen, auch zweimal. Also da ist schon Potenzial da. Und wie gesagt, das Umschaltspiel ist ziemlich gut. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, eine kontrollierte Offensive mit schnellem Umschaltspiel.
Iglesias, gerade auf Platz drei der Torschützenliste, auf Platz zwei Iago Aspas von Celta Vigo und auf Platz eins ein gewisser Robert Lewandowski mit sechs Toren in vier Einsätzen. Und damit sind wir beim letzten Thema. Jetzt geht es dann doch nochmal am Schluss um die großen zwei. Du hast überschrieben, Lewa ballert bei Barca, Real marschiert easy vorneweg. Was müssen wir zu Real und Barca wissen?
Ja, Real gefällt mir jetzt noch nicht so richtig gut bisher, aber sie machen es relativ souverän und easy going. Ohne jetzt groß das Feuerwerk abzubrennen. Benzema ist auch noch überhaupt nicht in Form, hat sich ja auch nochmal verletzt. Aber es reicht qualitativ einfach im Moment dicke nach wie vor in La Liga und in der Champions League werden wir es ja dann auch sehen. Da sind sie ja nochmal extrem gereizt, die Königlichen, wenn es dann wirklich aufs europäische Parkett geht. Also nee, im Endeffekt hat Angelotti den Kader der letzten Saison beigebehalten und punktuell verstärkt den Abgang von Casimiro mit –ich kann den Namen immer nicht aussprechen –Choumeni oder so ähnlich. Dem jungen Franzosen aus Monaco, der auch einen wahnsinnig guten Eindruck bisher hinterlässt, hat jetzt am Wochenende nicht gespielt. Das erste Mal ist geschont worden, ist aber einer der stärksten Spieler schon bei Real Madrid. Kamar Winger ist einer, der da eben nachdrücken kann. Also im Endeffekt haben sie den Kader nur leicht, aber punktuell verstärkt, oder was heißt leicht? Wenig verstärkt, was die Anzahl der Spieler anbelangt, aber eben sehr, sehr, sehr gut auf jeder Position. Und im Endeffekt ist es das Große der letzten Jahre mit Ancelotti vorne dran. Die führen sich im Moment, hat man so das Gefühl, fast von alleine und spazieren da so durch die Liga, fünf Spiele, fünf Siege, auch gegen Betis Sevilla. Da war es mal kurz eins zu eins, aber dann hatte man dann doch das Zwei zu eins erzählen können und hat das Spiel dann auch nach Hause gebracht. Also Real marschiert da vorne weg, ohne sich jetzt bisher große Strecken haben zu müssen. Und Barcelona wird dieses Jahr tatsächlich wieder auf Augenhöhe mit Real Madrid sein. Und unter anderem eben dank Robert Lewandowski, denn der macht eigentlich genau da weiter, wo aber Bayern aufgehört hat. Nämlich, ja, jeder Ball, den er in Straufland bekommt und mehr oder weniger aus Tor bekommt, ist eigentlich fast drin. Ich denke mal, die spanische Liga kommt ihm da auch zugute, denn Spanier sind, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen für einen schönen Offensivfußball bekannt. Nicht unbedingt die defensiv akribischsten Arbeiter. Und ich denke mal, wie gesagt, Lewandowski gegen die Mannschaften 8 bis Platz 20. Wenn er dann einen Ball eben im Straufraum hat, dann hat er keine große Mühe bisher, da seine Tore zu erzielen. Und er ist bereits der gefeierte Held in Barcelona. Die lieben ihn bereits sehr. Alle, die ich auch kenne hier, die Spanier, die mich kennen und die auch wissen, dass ich normalerweise Bayern München sehr gerne verfolge, weil ich aus der Gegend komme, die klopfen mir auf die Schulter und bedanken sich nochmal persönlich bei mir, dass wir ihn zu Barcelona verkauft haben. Also, die sind sehr, sehr happy. Und haben aber auch natürlich noch ein paar andere neue Spieler geholt. Also, Barcelona ist für mich tatsächlich dieses Jahr wieder auf Augenhöhe. Und ich denke, in der Hinsicht haben wir wahrscheinlich zumindest einen interessanten Zweikampf, was dann das Titelrennen anbelangt dieses Jahr.
Wir nehmen jetzt natürlich auch auf an dem Tag, an dem am Abend auch Bayern gegen Barca antreten wird. Ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie das Spiel vorwegnehmen, das ist kaum zu prognostizieren. Was mir allerdings aufgefallen ist, war eine –ich würde es dann doch schon gewisse Überheblichkeit nennen –in der Rezeption der Medien, dass man jetzt erneut wieder gegen Barca spielt. Kann das sein, dass noch nicht alle mitbekommen haben, dass das Barca aus dem letzten Jahr und auch das von vor zwei Jahren vielleicht gar nicht mehr so viel leistungstechnisch mit dem zu tun hat, wie Barca jetzt auftritt?
Da sollte man wirklich gewarnt sein, denn heute kommt ein ganz anderes Barca in die Allianz Arena. Ich denke, auch unter Xavi haben sie sich vor allem defensiv verbessert. Da haben sie auch noch die eine oder andere Verpflichtung gemacht. Es wird nicht einfach, es wird kein Spaziergang. Ich finde im Mittelfeld sehr, sehr interessant die jungen Spanier, Pedro und Gavi, die sind unwahrscheinlich krasse Talente. Beide werden dort über Jahre dominieren, werden so ein bisschen das Xavi und Iniesta der jetzigen Zeit werden.
Der eine ist 19, Pedro ist 18.
Die sind unglaublich. Schaut euch die heute Abend an, oder wenn ihr mal die Chance habt, ein Barca-Spiel zu sehen. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, was die schon in dem Alter für eine Spielgewitztheit haben und auch was für eine Ruhe sie bereits dem Spiel aufdrücken können, wenn es eben gebraucht wird. Hinten haben sie dann noch den Busquets, der dann auch durch seine Erfahrung die Bälle schön verteilt. Und natürlich Frenkie de Jong, der nicht Barca verlassen wollte, obwohl er ja zu so einem Wechsel überredet werden sollte. Denn Barca hat ja auch Geld gebraucht im Sommer. Der hat sich aber auch gedacht, hey, jetzt bin ich seit zwei Jahren bei Barca, jetzt gibt es endlich ein wettbewerbsfähiges Spiel.
Kaum macht es Spaß hier zu sein.
Und bekommt jetzt seine Einsatzzeit und macht das auch richtig gut. Also Barca hat abwehrmäßig, mittelfeldmäßig und im Sturm natürlich im Moment extrem sich verbessert. Und das wird heute Abend eine ganz enge Kiste, glaube ich.
Wir werden es ja dann verfolgen. Und dann sind wir mal gespannt, Fabian. Ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit. Fabian Pakulat, der Ed-Rosengartler, auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Ja, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und bis zum nächsten Mal. Viele Grüße.
Genau, bis zum nächsten Mal. Und an dieser Stelle dann auch nochmal herzlichen Dank an die anderen Gäste, die ihr vorhin schon hören konntet. Ich hoffe, euch hat diese Ligatour gefallen. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und hört auch gerne die Schlusskonferenzen. Unter anderem ist da erschienen eine Vorschau auf die Frauen-Bundesligasaison. Die möchte ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen. Bei mir war es wieder so, je mehr ich mich mit den Teams beschäftigt habe, desto größer ist die Vorfreude auf diese neue Saison geworden, die ihr jetzt am Freitag schon startet. Also hört auch die Schlusskonferenz und dann bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!